let's get the latest on the war in
Ukraine now in kiev's mayor says Russian
air strikes on the capital have killed
at least one person 15 cruise missiles
have reportedly been shot down by
Ukrainian air defenses though let's get
more now from Natasha Butler who's in
Kiev Natasha what's the latest from the
capital and Elsewhere on the front line
well there's an ongoing uh air alert uh
across Ukraine including uh here in Kiev
Sirens surrounding a little bit earlier
this morning what we know is Ukrainian
military officials say that 30 cruise
missiles were launched against Ukraine
key city council here saying that 15
were intercepted missiles that they say
were heading in the direction of the
capital and then just over an hour ago
we heard a very loud explosion coming
from that direction over there where we
now know that that was the result of a
rocket hitting a non-residential
building at least one person has been
killed we understand and at least
another person has been injured so
that's the scene that people are waking
up to here in Kiev this morning after a
very tense night Airaid Sirens
throughout the night people advised to
seek shelter Ukrainian forces saying 24
or russian-launched iranian-made drones
were launched across the country and
shot down by Ukrainian forces some of
them around the capital Kiev and the
district here now some regions have put
in place emergency power Cuts advising
people also not to use too much power
because in the past of course in the
past weeks we have seen Uh Russian
forces continuously Target uh emergence
critical infrastructure in the country
all right we have to leave it there
thanks very much for the update Natasha
Butler live for us in cave